Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at why some
devices have two-prong plugs and others have
three.
To provide a source of power, electricity
must flow in a circuit.
(Although, you might be surprised to learn
the net velocity of the flow of the electrons
is actually quite a bit slower than a turtle,
which you can learn all about in this video.)
In a typical American outlet, the circuit
is comprised of a right vertical slot connected
to the “hot” wire and a larger left vertical
slot connected to the “neutral” wire.
The plugged in device itself (the load) completes
the circuit, with power flowing through it.
So what’s the third prong needed for then?
This third prong is the ground.
Both the neutral and the ground are connected
to an earth ground in the main breaker box
in your home.
The difference between the two is that the
neutral completes a circuit with the hot wire
and normally carries some amount of current
(which is why it’s insulated), while the
ground does not normally carry any current
whatsoever and is not connected to the circuit
at all (unless something has gone wrong).
It simply is used to connect the external
conductive parts of the device to the earth
and, thus, in normal operation is completely
unnecessary.
This is why you can use a 3-prong to 2-prong
plug adapter to bypass having to use the ground
line and the device will still work just fine.
So why have both a neutral and a ground when
they both ultimately just tie to the earth
ground bar in the main breaker box?
Among a few other benefits, this is primarily
so that if something should go awry with the
device, like a stray hot or neutral wire coming
into contact with the outer conductive parts
of the device (for instance, if the insulation
wears away or a wire comes loose), you don’t
die or get seriously injured if you touch
the device and it’s plugged in.
You see, absent a separate ground in such
a malfunction, once you touched the conductive
bits of the device, you may become the path
to ground and a surge of electricity would
flow through you until ultimately tripping
the breaker in your breaker box.
With the separate ground, the electricity
simply surges through that wire until the
breaker is tripped, cutting off power to that
line when the surge is detected.
This not only helps to ensure you don’t
get shocked, but also reduces the chances
of a fire starting due to the short via making
sure the breaker is tripped immediately after
the short happens.
So what about the devices that lack this third
ground prong?
How is this safe?
They (usually) have at least two layers of
insulation between the conductive components
of the device and any part of the device you
can touch.
To achieve this cheaply, the outer casing
of these devices are often made entirely of
plastic or some other non-conductive material.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And of course if you’re new to TodayIFoundOut,
don’t forget to click the subscribe button
to get more interesting videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.